okay yeah go ahead and introduce
yourself yes this is 27 year old louis
sarah betty from the UK who is able to
write words on her skin I've never seen
anything like that is she like allergic
to the pan or something how exactly does
the wheeze use her arm like a notepad so
this is an example of Dometic raffia
which basically means brought in on the
scheme when you have this condition you
have very sensitive skin and it reacts
also to pressure so this is Dermot oh
graffia but what's actually happening
this is quite a complicated chemical
reaction that she's causing here first
of all the receptors on the mass cells
just underneath the skin will cause the
release of histamine into the
bloodstream something that you would
naturally associate with an allergic
reaction so if you think about when
you've had high fever or an allergy to
dust or pollen that often means that you
get swelling or itchy skin so the same
thing happens here the release of
histamine is actually causing those
capillaries to become leaky and this is
actually the immune systems response on
it's causing this leakage and this
puffiness and extreme increase in blood
flow to that area to try to correct the
damage that's been done so Louise is not
having any allergic reaction it's just
the mechanical trauma that leads to the
release of histamines it's not painful
it just gets a bit itchy bit red rubbing
my skin is it also going swimming or
something that can be a bit embarrassing
but I'm used to it now it is quite fun
to draw